on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensor the
kiss the crisis and the comeuppance
after facing me for two hours Louisa
biales is now preparing to face a
criminal court but does he deserve it
Kim Jong-un means Vladimir Putin is the
deadly dictator's broken deals over
weapons in space but the real Star Wars
begun I'll talk to stargazing Superstar
Neil deGrasse Tyson about that and a lot
more
or should we have to repatriate antiques
over the colonial Links of BBC experts
Barks A Furious debate
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored canary
from London welcome to piersburg with
uncensor the story of Louis rubials has
dominated headlines for many weeks more
people have seen that kiss and probably
watched the Women's World Cup final
which is a travesty in itself but that's
because this has become a story about so
much more than football it's about the
way men treat women about abuse of power
about cancel culture about our Changing
Times at its heart there's a man who
clearly overstepped the mark in a moment
of wild celebration the way he's behaved
since kissing Jenny hermoso has turned
Sparks of controversy into a raging
Inferno rubiolis shouldn't have done
what he did he could have danced the
Flames much sooner by admitting his
mistakes after sitting next to him for
nearly two hours I think he's still
making some mistakes throughout our
interview he wouldn't apologize directly
to Jenny hermoso he keeps saying you're
sorry and you made a mistake and you
shouldn't have done it
but you won't say sorry to Jenny
personally and I'm curious why you're
reluctant to do that
so what we had is a spontaneous act a
mutual active
which was driven by the emotion of the
moment the happiness
many times he declined my well my offer
to him to say sorry to the woman that he
kissed that way but despite admitting
that he was wrong he shouldn't have done
it he wouldn't say sorry I thought that
was a mistake
he was also very prepared to immediately
issue a very groveling apology to the
queen of Spain for well grabbing his
crotch in front of her and a 16 year old
daughter
he was sitting just a few seats away
from Queen Leticia in Spain and her 16
year old daughter infanta Sophia The
Princess and you very provocatively
grabbed your crotch
in a way that frankly I watched that and
thought that just with members of the
royal family sitting there and a young
16 year old girl again was completely
inappropriate
for this I am truly ashamed do you
apologize to the queen have you
personally apologized to her no because
I I couldn't have the opportunity to to
speak with
with the queen would you like to
apologize to her now no no yes I did I
did I mean directly to her yes of course
again
happy to apologize to the queen who was
sitting a few feet away but not happy to
apologize to the woman that he kissed in
the way that he did which he admits was
wrong I'm sure the queen and her
daughter didn't appreciate the crotch
crab but Jenny hermoso is a woman who
didn't appreciate that kiss she's made
that pretty clear in the last three
weeks and of course the celebrations
of winning the World Cup the greatest
moment of any football player's life
have been completely overshadowed by
that kiss surely rubial should be the
one saying sorry to the person that he
did that to but he wouldn't and when you
peel back the layers of his Saga it does
get quite complicated rubial is insists
and this may be why he won't offer the
apology that he asked Jenny hermoso If
he if he could kiss her and he says lip
readers will be able to prove that maybe
they will maybe they won't it's clear
that Jenny Hermosa initially downplayed
the incident this is what she said on
radio immediately afterwards
foreign
so it was nothing apparently but then it
became something it's also clear from
the videos on the team bus on the night
that they won the World Cup there's lots
of laughter chance of Prezi Prezi
president and bezo bezo kiss no sign
there really of any great traumatic
experience that had just occurred no
sign of the furian Scandal that was to
come now that doesn't mean that what he
did was right it wasn't it doesn't mean
that a woman can't change her mind about
whether she thinks something was
acceptable or not in the way that Jenny
hermoso did but it does mean that for
whatever reason the goal posts moved in
the few days that followed what happened
now on Friday Ruby eyes will appear in
court in Spain his kids could buy to his
job dramatically during our interview
and he could kiss goodbye to his freedom
too if he's found guilty he could face
one to four years in prison hermoso
filed a criminal complaint of sexual
assault against Ruby Allis and will
testify at the high court in Madrid but
is that really where this Saga should
end up in a courtroom there are powerful
forces on both sides of the debate who
are wrestling to reframe our sense of
right and wrong the guardian reviewed
the interview called it sickening and an
illusion of good journalism which I took
has been one of the best reviews I've
ever had from the guardian it also slide
rubiolis as a symbol of Macho culture
prevalent and embedded in capitalist
Society worldwide wow well I've been
waiting to review anyone exclusive in
the guardian for a very very very long
time but they don't actually break any
and honestly when I read the review I
found that rather sickening and cliched
and predictable
surely the reasonable verdict on the
rubial is Scandal is this
he made a mistake he got overexcited he
was wrong he was inappropriate he should
absolutely apologize and perhaps
he should have lost his job although I
think the jury's out on that just
speaking to people anecdotally that I've
spoken to about this but some people
I suspect a lot of people at the
guardian won't be happy until he's
locked up in a prison cell and taking
the blame for every male sin in this
world of apparent toxic masculinity that
everyone has to endure and I think that
is wrong too
would you want me to debate this is
football journalist Mina razuki the
president of the Norwegian Football
Association Lee klavanus Spanish
football journalist and author guillaine
balaguey and Senior fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and author Heather
McDonald so we've got a great panel for
this and it is complicated now Amina I
can see you slightly rolling your eyes
at some of the things I was saying there
um what's your view of this
I am outraged so I am one of those
people that I'm sorry but I do agree
with the way that the guardian has put
this I don't think this is what has been
portrayed in this interview is that this
is an isolated incident this poor man
went on stage and he kissed a girl out
of Celebration and now we're debating
whether or not it's well no one called
no one called him a poor man I didn't
express any sympathy for what he'd done
I said what he did was wrong as did he
the question becomes was what we
witnessed literally in one of the most
watched events in the world the World
Cup final Podium as the organ was that a
crime
you have to apply context because
everything in its isolation is regarded
we're now debating what happened as an
isolated incident but what we need to
know is the man we need to understand
the full context of this that won't be
relevant to any court case the court
case will be about whether what he did
constitute sexual assault there won't be
the context of what may have gone on
with disputes over pay and stuff with
the Spanish women's team it will purely
be about the kiss so we're debating only
whether or not this is a criminal case I
I think so because I think that he's
lost his job so you can say that could
take in all the other stuff all right
maybe he shouldn't be president
um and that's a perfectly legitimate
argument I just don't think what we
witnessed constitutes any kind of crime
and I'm not sure that most people feel
that but you do you
yes I do I only feel that if my boss
comes in and decides to celebrate with
me by by kissing me and cultural
conformity and as women have learned to
do on most occasion is taking on the
chin or not perhaps make a big deal out
of it perhaps you know slap him on the
podium there and then uh go in and you
know everyone's just won the World Cup
you have to just celebrate with everyone
but you in your heart of hearts
understand that something's gone wrong
but you cannot or have the emotional
capacity to process this but he is still
your boss who has launched himself on
you and then gone downstairs to the
dressing room to then tell everyone that
he wants to marry and they're all
invited to this
I think that that would put me in a very
vulnerable state and if I was to process
that emotion
what what exactly are my my options over
here how is this man allowed to do this
and then at the end of the day I am
being questioned they are threatening me
with legal action they are calling me a
liar when he has done this action in
front of everyone and has shown time and
time again
I think you make some very good points
particularly about the way they tried to
demonize I thought it was completely
wrong
um they should never have done that how
do you explain the radio interview she
gave dismissing it all is nothing the
fact that on the team bus they're all
laughing and joking the fact in the
dressing room actually when they're
offered the trip to Ibiza and he's
obviously joking about the marrying
thing
um but that again the atmosphere appears
to be very light and jocular
so I've been in in certain positions
before somebody who works in men's
football especially in in which you walk
into a situation and they joke with you
but it's all jokes and there was no seat
available for our production meeting and
they will say come sit on my lamp
what is exactly my options to respond to
this I either laugh and joke and play it
off because that is my instinct to
survival to culturally conform to
society ideals uh or I make a big deal
of it and then I put my my job on the
line and these are the decisions that
we're faced with every day I understand
that so everyone keeps talking about
whether or not or her reaction so if I
was to abuse a little boy every day but
he doesn't you know go to the police or
he doesn't show to himself to be trauma
uh induced or sitting in a corner then
it's okay I can continue to abuse this
little boy it's not about how she has
reacted to to the situation it is about
what he's done and we don't talk about
enough about what he's done as being the
problem and if we don't stop this now
what is the next step he has lost a very
high profile powerful job as a
consequence of this so the consequences
are clear I think my my point would be
is bringing Professor McDonald here my
point of professors is about whether
this is proportionate now to take this
to a courtroom do you think it is
well I would say this appears that if
women are so fragile and so vulnerable
that a spontaneous split-second kiss in
the context of mass Elation almost Mass
hysteria can traumatize women at that to
that degree I don't want them serving in
combat units which is it are women
strong and capable of of fighting Wars
or are they so fragile that a
spontaneous act that is not never to be
repeated can send them into a state of
of complete breakdown as Mina said
context is all this happened in the
context of group Mass Elation clearly he
did not walk up to her in out of the
blue in a boardroom meeting this
happened she lifted him up first she's
that strong she has no shrinking violet
her behavior you're in the locker room
afterwards she was defying Grim you know
grimacing to the camera
tattooed she is not a a fragile woman
she said herself in her initial
statement this was an absolutely
accurate uh portrayal of this event it
was a mutual gesture totally spontaneous
prompted by Joy feminists have become
martinets they have no tolerance for for
for ambiguity for human foibles this is
a travesty that he is being
criminally prosecuted for something that
had no lingering effects I can guarantee
you hermoso does not fear that she is
going to be stalked by Louis rubialis
let's bring in again below you know you
are the token man on this panel game so
uh a lot rests on your next few words
I've read your tweets on this I know
you've been quite scathing about rubials
you think it's right that he's stepped
down uh what do you feel about the wider
context of this as it now heads towards
a courtroom do you think we've lost a
sense of proportion or do you think that
actually he should be held accountable
criminally potentially for what happened
in fact you lose a sense of proportion
when all you talk about is the case and
rubialis this is part of a wider context
my question to royales would be
how can you think that what you've done
was right and that you needed a whole
wave of social protest for you to
actually change your mind and I must say
the apologies that he did to you were
much more sincere that the ones that did
it the day after and for me if me too
was about pointing out criminal uh
behavior of men to watch Mormon in in
this case the CIA Cabo the enough is
enough hashtag that Alexia putayas put
in first it's about let's stop things
that have been normalized like a boss
and because you said the context is not
important in our court case in this
court case is very important because
it's a boss doing it to an employee oh
no no sorry just to clarify that that is
so important yeah to clarify that I
think that's absolutely important the
power imbalance I think is important
what I meant was the the history of the
kind of arguments that have been going
on between the Spanish Football
Federation and the women's team which
led to so many of the women not playing
in the World Cup and so on about pay
equal rights and so on I don't think any
of that is going to be relevant in the
courtroom the courtroom will simply be
studying This Kiss to see whether it
constitutes a sexual assault and he was
very firm in the interview repeatedly
that he believes that the full evidence
when it's laid there will support his
view that he asked permission first now
if that is true if he's able to
establish that does that change the
narrative
if he establishes that we may change the
The Narrative and let's see what the
Core case and the judge the size
eventually in in the high court because
legally uh cases similar like that have
come out with that yes he's guilty and
now he's guilty so we cannot get into
the legality of it and that's why by the
way he did not deal with Daniel Marshall
apologizing to the general motion would
have put it in a weaker position to the
meeting that he's going to have Friday
right the caucus that comes forward but
I go back to this idea in which world
does he live in well he thinks that this
is fine I tell you the world he lives in
a world in which the assembly the
general assembly of the Federation with
43 members only seven a woman a world in
which and these are decision makers in
the Federation well in which the heads
of the local federations of Spain that
also choose the next president they're
all men that's the world he lives in and
these are people that is chosen that he
pays directly or indirectly for them to
say yes to him that's the world that he
lives in and I think he's in shock that
the majority of his Spanish people
almost unanimously are saying enough
that's definitely not on I think I I do
think he was in shock I think he was in
shock in the immediate aftermath hence
his kind of attack on his critics then
the penny began to drop that he'd done
something which most people found
completely unacceptable I have to say to
his credit he didn't try and hide the
fact that he he realized now what he'd
done was completely wrong I think the
the only debate left is whether it
should now move to a criminal court let
me bring in Lisa Clavin has been
listening very patiently president of
the Norwegian Football Association so
you hold this job in Norway what have
you made of of the whole scandal of
course I've paid much attention I was
there in the final Luis rubelles is a
colleague of mine I know I known him
from before not not personally but met
him several times and during my campaign
and when I ran for the UEFA Expo as the
first women and a woman in history to
run for an open position and and I met
him as a friendly and respectful
colleague so so it's a difficult case to
to comment on an individual basis
because now it's a criminal case and
that's not relevant to me so the context
I see it in is in in the football
context Daniel hermoso to me is a great
football player she's a world champion
she's of course the robust player she's
a great Pastor great finisher so that's
the context that is overshadowed and
that is that is also the context we have
to see it in and I feel responsible to
to bring in that context because it's
also societal important that we do it
because it's the biggest sport in the
world for for girls and women and it's
been systematically
unbalanced for for 50 to 100 years and
now we see this frustration piling up
and of course for rubialis it's a what
he called it mediatric tsunami of course
it's to him and to Jenny Hermos so this
is now we're going to follow them and
see how do they act of course they're
both in under tremendous pressure but
what he has to realize and I think he
will realize every person can make
mistakes but the context here was also
that the Federation was in in a fight or
in a
in a battle with with the female players
for years and years so that is also a
context uh that is very relevant also
through the whole society and that we
really need change we really need change
I think the the real shame of this
actually is that it totally eclipsed the
Magnificent achievement not just of the
Spanish team winning but actually the
event itself being such a dramatic
success with huge sellout stadiums
massive TV ratings this was the real
coming of age I think of the of women's
football as a global sport and a massive
success and rather than talking about
that and all the positives we've spent
three and a half weeks talking about a
bloke kissing the winning Captain which
seems to me completely wrong
unfortunately we've run out of time I'm
really sorry but thank you very much to
it excellent panel a lot of range of
opinions here you know for what it's
worth as I said at the start of all this
I don't think you should be heading to a
courtroom I think the punishment enough
of losing his powerful job as president
and being humiliated globally which he
has been the last three and a half weeks
should probably be suffice but we will
see thank you very much indeed to my
panel I appreciate it and says the next
World Famous astrophysicist Neil
deGrasse Tyson who turns to unsense and
he's promising to take us to infinity
and beyond you don't get that with every
guest
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think it's only one for one king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail stop working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
wall you're making me cry again I'm
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
Lucy Letty will die behind bars and a
senior Doctor Who first raised concerns
about that he wants NHS manages to be
regulated we needed answers a lot sooner
this is what seven years down the line I
mean it's completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
way TK team that would make her a better
princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell agreed
to be interviewed for the very first
time I obviously wish I'd never met him
Donald Trump has just said he expects to
be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the Kentucky party can certainly win the
next election yes
did you say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
introducing oil the knock-on effect is
far larger than just CO2 I nearly have
empathy when I'm speaking to them I know
you're probably going to vote me after
church
some of them they're easily LED
you can kiss my American Air
thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
well now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the trails you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should you be
concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to peers organized since
Kim Jong-un of Vladimir Putin another
Russian Spaceport today to talk about
potential weapons and satellite
technology deals the world's most deadly
and shortest dictators told the rocket
launch site before sitting down for a
press conference they talked about
prioritizing the Strategic importance of
North Korea Russia relations which
should send a send a shutter down all
our spines is this new warring
development in the real Star Wars or are
Kim and vladis trivial bit part players
in a new Global Space Race well who
better to ask than the world's what is
the most brilliant and the world's most
famous astrophysicist Neil deGrasse
Tyson so pleased I've been back on the
show Neil great to see you
yeah thanks for having me thanks for
having me back so Kim Jong-un Vladimir
Putin and space seems an Unholy Trilogy
what is your view of what what went down
today
yeah I mean I you know I wasn't in the
conversation but seeing the images uh
it's it's a little bit worrisome because
space is is we've known for decades
though it's a it's a new high ground and
from a military strategic perspective
High Ground gives you power uh Power
that you didn't previously have so yes
this this Alliance of of Nations that
we're not friendly with uh now that
we're not friendly with concerns me but
what considers me even more is space can
be a place where we all come together
for peaceful purposes more so than
anything we might ever do on Earth's
surface so uh for me it's an extra
offense for anyone to speak of space
Weaponry because in space well yeah you
can have borders of countries on Earth
in space there are no borders right it's
just space and so it to me it's a
violation of a
a human
our species contract with the universe
if I could call it yeah no when you saw
for example India launching Rockets
um last week I think it was I mean I
found that very uplifting to watch that
it's amazing to watch exciting I
remember took me right back to the 60s
and 70s when I used to watch all the
rocket launches as a kid uh what did you
feel watching all that
yeah so uh you're probably talking about
the mission that where they landed near
the South Pole of the Moon as the
graphic there uh shows so they're the
first country to land in that part of
the Moon the South Pole might have a
repository of water trapped in the base
of craters where the sun don't shine
because the rim of the crater is higher
than the angle that the sun will ever
reach it and so the history of comet
impacts and other things water brought
to the Moon would evaporate where the
sun shines but stay forever where the
sun doesn't shine and so they're the
first there this was great they were
dancing in the streets yes and I I was
so and they become the fourth country to
softly land on the moon adjoining and so
the idea that this becomes a a world
where countries participate uh so that
it becomes the solar system becomes our
Collective backyard am I am I too naive
to think that that's possible I I don't
know well it's interesting it's a bit
artificial intelligence you know a lot
of it is incredibly exciting and you
know wildly like you know you can go
into wild New Frontiers of potential and
of course there's another part of me
thinks this is going to be incredibly
dangerous because the wrong people will
get their hands on AI and do bad things
with it
yeah so that's a very important
observation to make because the press
that AI is getting today leads people to
think that all AI is bad when in my
field we've been using AI for decades at
some levels or another and every next
power of AI that comes on on online we
absorb it because we let it do the work
I don't want to do the work right I have
other things I can do yeah so so yeah it
shouldn't indict the entire Enterprise
of AI because you can imagine some parts
of AI turning Rogue so with space yeah I
I want space to be peaceful think about
it in the International Space Station it
is a joint project with Russia and the
United States and other countries so if
countries can't get along on Earth do
you expect astronauts in space to say
okay separate don't talk to each other
because our leaders can't get along
that's almost childish to expect that
when you have scientists and engineers
in space doing real interesting work two
stories near that I when I saw them I
thought of you immediately one is that
scientists at Nasa have announced the
existence of a possible planet that
could sustain a life tell me about this
yeah so that's uh the James Webb Space
Telescope if it's the new story I'm
thinking about uh it has the power to
observe the atmosphere
and the chemical composition of the
atmosphere of exoplanets if the planet
passes in front of the host star light
from the host star will move through the
air and the chemicals in the atmosphere
will leave its fingerprint in the
spectrum that we receive and it found
methane it found carbon dioxide and
these consider these as biomarkers if
there's evidence of life on the surface
it may if there's life on the surface it
may manifest in the chemistry of the
atmosphere and it's in the Goldilocks
zone where you can sustain liquid water
too close the water evaporates too far
the water freezes everywhere there's
liquid water on Earth there's life if
not fishes then there's microbial life
so NASA's Mantra is follow the water if
you want to find life and if we so if
this so if I'm ready for the the list of
planets to go to uh we'll rank them
based on these kinds of evidence right
to say if we want to have a second Earth
or move somewhere let's try this one
first and then the next one and then the
next one because plenty of the
exoplanets would be fully in
inhospitable to Life as We Know It
fascinating uh the other thing was UFOs
of the US Congress convened this panel
about unidentified anomalous phenomenon
uaps to try and work out what we do and
don't know
um at the same time as we're speaking
this is freaky but as we're speaking
about the Mexican Parliament someone's
just produced images of alien corpses uh
in the Mexican Parliament and said
they're alien corpses so I guess my
question for you Neil is do you believe
that there are loads of aliens out there
do you believe that governments perhaps
know more than we do
um and should we be fearful about this
yeah so first of all those are not
images of alien corpses in Mexico those
are presented as actual alien mummified
aliens from like a thousand years ago so
here's what you do when we went to the
moon we brought moon rocks back and NASA
allowed scientists of the world to
analyze those rocks it's shared samples
with everyone rather than give it to
only one lab so if those are actual
mummified aliens
found in Mexico or wherever they were I
overheard the press conference they said
they carbon 14 dated it it has 30
percent overlap DNA with humans if those
are aliens that would be amazing but in
science you need verification from
independent sources so what they should
do as we know from ale from from mummies
uh there's still a soft tissue in the
mummies they beat carbon-14 dated that I
don't know if you did it on the soft
tissue or on the bones but my point is
you share the data with other
Laboratories and when you have agreement
among what is measured then you can talk
about it as a discovery but the Press
loves chasing singular stories by one
laboratory that says no one else has
this but we do y'all just run to that
and report it like it's the truth so but
science is not established by single
measurements or observations
are you saying we tend to sensationalize
these things now
[Laughter]
yes you did yes you did let's take a
short break I want to come back and talk
about your brilliant new book to
infinity and beyond and about vegans and
about God maybe not even in that order
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
scientist in the universe ever Professor
Neil deGrasse Tyson whose new book just
to do a bit of media sensationalism his
new book to infinity and beyond is out
this month it's it's absolutely riveting
you write about this stuff so
brilliantly you bring it all so alive
um I'm going to go into a few things but
first of all
the key question for me with all this
well especially I was reading your book
how much do you think we know and how
much do you think we don't know about
what's out there
that's a great question and I can
actually quantify that answer so there's
there are these things this dark matter
you might have heard about so dark
matter is 85 it's responsible for 85
percent of the gravity in the universe
and we have no idea what it is but we
can measure it there's Dark Energy
responsible for the accelerated
expansion of the universe we can measure
that but we don't know what's causing it
and then you add up all of these sort of
what these forces are doing in the
universe it's 96 of what's driving the
universe and all the forces of nature
that we know and love gravity uh
electromagnetism the strong and weak
nuclear forces life chemistry biology
physics that's in four percent of the
universe so we know enough about the
universe
to quantify our ignorance
so we know four percent of what's going
on out there but also keep in mind that
as the area of our knowledge grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance
and that is the very soul of science
that their questions people say what
questions do you want answered I don't
think that way I think what question do
I not even yet know yes I think that's
the really interesting part is that
you're probably not even thinking of a
great question right because there may
be something correct that's I I lose
sleep over that yes no how do you I know
you're an avowed atheist how can you be
so certain that there is no Supernatural
god-like entity out there given that we
know so little
well first I I don't count myself among
the ranks of a valid atheists and I'll
give a fast example why a friend of mine
went up to fix the Hubble telescope okay
on the space shuttle and on my on my on
my Facebook feed I said godspeed to the
Space Shuttle astronauts and then in the
comment thread it said I thought you
were an atheist how could you possibly
say that and so the fact that I
gleefully said that and atheists
complained about it clearly I'm not an
atheist what are you my favorite my
favorite Broadway musical of all time is
Jesus Christ Superstar which I saw in
real time in New York City and I don't
know that atheists so I don't so is
there
Tyson I'll be about to have breakfast I
don't know is there a God
okay what so I will tell you is that
with there are a lot of unknowns in the
universe but just because they're
unknowns does not mean there's a deity
in the unknown if you're gonna it
doesn't mean there isn't that which
it doesn't mean there isn't that's
correct
about this right
everyone should if the unknown is the
unknown but the the the the track record
of people saying God is behind this and
then you add a little science to it and
you find out no we can completely
explain it and control it then that the
history of that exercise is so rich with
science
discovering the unknowns that were
previously ascribed to deity like
lightning bolts and weather systems
there was Poseidon there was Zeus there
was just look at the history of this I'm
I'm not given reason to say we're going
to find something God is going to be at
the center of that and there'll be no
science to apply I'm going to look for
the science first because that's how the
history of this exercise is unfolded I
want to play you a clip this is you
talking to Joe Rogan about vegans
you want to save animals
um I never seen I've never seen anyone
say
save the leeches no no one cares about
bugs save the ticks and you can ask
if you really into animals and don't
want to kill them if you heard that
ticks were endangered would you start a
movement to protect ticks would you do
that
and if you would of more power to you
but I'm thinking you're not
they're not it's the little guys they
don't care about I've had this debate
with vegans I won last week I have it
every month and I always point out most
vegans I know Munch away on almonds and
avocados and they turn a blind eye to
the fact that this causes the mass
murder of billions of bees mainly in
California they don't want to have that
debate because I don't care about the
little guys Neil
yeah but my only reaction there is
um that comment was addressing only
vegans who are vegans because they don't
want to kill animals no I agree other
reasons to be vegan of corporate Health
the ones who run into steakhouses
playing sounds of cows being slaughtered
they're the ones that Munch avocados and
armors invariably yeah and by the way
and they are dining upon the
reproductive organs of plants that's
kind of weird and I imagine if if a
plant-based alien visited Earth they
would freak out when they saw
vegetarians yes because the virgins
would be eating them right and and and
vegetarians Target
um not only the reproductive organs the
nuts the berries the flowers but they
also Target the infant versions of it
with baby lettuce baby carrots baby this
would terrify a plant-based alien so
that's just a cosmic perspective on that
no no you've given me you have given me
a whole new line of attack the the
flower babies I love it this is
fantastic uh I I I just they I find this
way that's dangerous if it's dangerous
to feed you more lines of attack because
I don't know what you're gonna do with
it well I always like to say these
things to them debates to their logical
end right I mean and it seems to me they
when it suits them they care about the
bigger animals the cuddly ones but when
it comes to the little guys they're not
interested um now I want to talk about
sorry the furry ones especially
something even more iconic actually the
god or vegans and it's your mustache
which has become one of the world's most
famous mustaches and his extraordinary
is a whole website that's been set up
called deGrasse Tyson's mustache and we
did a bit of research ourselves a bit of
scientific research uh and there's a
mustache Montage that we have here which
is quite extraordinary it turns out
almost every brilliant scientist has had
a magnificent Tash Nikola Tesla the
inventor extraordinaire great Tash Louis
de broglie the discovered the wave-like
nature of all matter great Tash Hans
Geiger famous for the geiger counter
Robert H Goddard built the first liquid
fueled rocket and of course Albert
Einstein probably the one nearest to
your own
um you I mean you've become the modern
day Godfather of science mustaches but
very much
running in a sort of a great long
historic list of great tashes
I I I never thought about it that this
mustache I've never shaved it in my life
yes I've trimmed it but it's ever since
I could grow a mustache I've had a
mustache so uh it's just part of my life
and even it was kind of out of style a
few years ago and I I was a little bit I
did get rid of my mutton chop sideburns
I figured okay that's from 1978 I could
lose those but I did keep the mustache
but if I were to vote among those
Mustangs yes I would say you know we
remember Einstein is this wire-haired
yeah you know gray big bushy eyebrows
but he was a dashing young man you see
him in a tuxedo yes look at that
mustache that's like a Magnum PI
mustache right there if you could final
question Neil if you could have dinner
tonight with any scientist in the
history of recording mankind who would
it be
yeah it would be oh no question about it
Isaac Newton but I think about that all
the time and I'd say Isaac come for
dinner and he'd look out the window and
he'd see these things moving he said
what are those and I said well they're
horse-drawn carriages without a horse he
said well how do they move well they use
gasoline what's gasoline oh it's fossil
fuels what's fossil fuels and after five
minutes it is I say go back to it
also unfortunately your answer there's
so much that has happened since then
well you're awesome I don't know if I
have the patience well you killed my
theory also because Isaac Newton
famously was clean shave
oh
well um Newton we see him with these big
locks of curls but I think that was
actually a wig on top of much shorter
hair and the statue of him in Cambridge
at the in a trinity in a church in
Cambridge
um it's you shoot you see him with short
hair wow so I was so disappointed when I
heard of that yeah
Neil I could honestly interview every
single day and it would never get boring
you've got a fantastic way of bringing
this stuff to life to infinity and
beyond a journey of cosmic Discovery
Neil deGrasse Tyson and Lindsay Walker
it's the number one New York Times
bestseller as all your books are it's a
fantastic reading great to have you back
in uncensor thank you
thank you
well it says to the next you'll be
unsurprised to hear that Sam Smith has
done something stupid again and will
debate whether antiques should be
returned to their native countries
here's back
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City King peers and King
cute I think there's only one for one
king
he's mopped your weight Trump yeah look
at him fail not working just because
their skin folk don't mean they're
kinfolks do you believe you can win this
war it's making me cry again they're
trying to force you out yes I feel
betrayed keep it award-winning
[Music]
dive behind and a senior Doctor Who
first raised concerns about that he
wants NHS managers to be regulated we
needed answers a lot sooner this is what
seven years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous we need
accountability we need performance in
all walks of life if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board should
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katie that would make her a
better princess of wealth Elaine Maxwell
agree to be interviewed for the very
first time I obviously wish I'd never
met him Donald Trump has just said he
expects to be arrested at 7 30 P.M
the conservi party can certainly win the
next election yes
did he say yes I have taken drugs and
they bent the rules or lied on the visa
application form and therefore got it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
rest your souls
let it roll
[Music]
stop producing oil the knock-on effect
is far larger than just CO2 I nearly
have empathy when I'm speaking to them I
know you're probably going to vote me
off
some of them they're easily lit
you can kiss my American ass thank you
very much
very nice of you
Twitter you Sons can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with us
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I'm the only one that has
been telling the truth you don't drink
never taken drug you're stinking Rich
should you be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV
it's about you and your opinions if
you're thinking about it we're talking
about it
it's all about me that's a joke
foreign
did you worry that you may lose
everything do you feel a great loss that
you didn't have the love of your parents
sound like my wife how long did he say
you had to live you've remained
extremely loyalty I can have a friend
that 15 other people don't like I could
give what everybody else thinks we're
going to see Conor McGregor Money
Changes Everything the incident on New
Year's Eve this is where we're going
with this interview huh
[Music]
it was a promo for my fascinating
interview with Dana White one of the
most interesting people in World sport
the founder of UFC has become this
multi-billion Dollar business and he's a
really interesting guy that's tomorrow
night for the hour Dana White honestly
even if you don't know about him you
will want to know about him by the time
you finish watching it's very
interesting stuff I'm joined by my pack
now Associates commentator Grace Blakely
Associated to the Daily Mirror Kevin
McGuire talk to these Esther cracker
well welcome to all of you Antiques
Roadshow shall we have a little clip
from Antiques Roadshow to get this going
so if there's a call for these things to
be repatriated would you be happy to do
that absolutely definitely
so this came about because
um sir Harold kittermaster governor of
the protectorate between 1926 and 1931
this was a back in Ethiopia was given a
golden robe and personal letter by Haley
Selassie uh who then was running the
country and apparently now he should be
giving this back right the family should
be giving this back what do we feel
about this Grace I mean this is all part
of the sort of
I guess paying reparations for sins of
our ancestors giving stuff back that
countries took from each other centuries
ago I don't really see the point of all
this because once you start where do you
stop oh well I mean the point is you
know it's you often see in response to
uh problems like this the idea that I
would have to undo all of human history
because things have changed hands so
many times over the course of you know
Millennia but what we are living with
today is a system of ongoing extraction
and kind of colonial domination that
exists in the world economy which means
that countries like Ethiopia remain very
poor because their resources are
extracted because
um you know they are the people that
live there are unable to move because
they are on the Forefront of issues like
climate change and we as a country are
very rich in pop because of the legacy
of colonialism and that's not something
that we've ever read what does that have
to do with this though because this was
a gift from Haile Selassie it was
actually a gift it wasn't it wasn't
stolen well this is I think the question
yeah we can talk in the abstract about
whether or not reparations are good or
bad or whether or not shouldn't we be
talking about whether the baby see in
their Flagship Antiques Roadshow program
whether they should be lecturing people
who bring their heirlooms along they've
been handed to them as gifts just send
it back and sort of morally bullying
them or black man I think it's a
historical because it actually you know
people that had these artifacts from
back back that date back to Millennia
actually there's an educational element
there so there was there was a point in
southern us where they found a giant
drum that was um you know traditional to
the akan people in West Africa and like
how the hell did this get here well
because it was it was sent over as a
gift right you have so many periods in
history where you see artifacts that are
a result of trade or some sort of
interaction between different types of
people why why would we suddenly have
this discourse of giving it back it was
it was well
look look according to Ronnie Archer
Morgan and antiques expert in an ethnic
tribal and folk art the robe is valued
in the region of four to five thousand
pounds it's not a huge amount of money
um I just don't like this idea now that
everyone that goes down under Antiques
Roadshow one of the least like
controversial programs imaginable you
literally open up the garage take your
stuff down and find out if you've got
lucky now you've got to feel as with
everything in Modern Life that the work
we go get their hands on is antique work
show they're calling it on social media
now you've got to feel guilty you've got
to be bullied into sending it somewhere
out of the country because your
great-great-grandfather who was gifted
it didn't realize in a hundred years
time we'd all feel so guilty about
everything cheers do you feel bullied by
the Antiques
I feel sad the Antiques won't because
it's the biggest rail about the Antiques
Roadshow since viewers complain that
they interrupted the program to show the
release of Nelson Mandela after 27 years
in prison
look it's it's a it's a program that
does trying to have a more General
understanding and just seeing there's a
there's a table uh that's worth 10 you
know 10 quid and so I think it's a fair
question to ask now and again and the
two granddaughters who have possession
of this rope we saw they didn't object
they said they'd consider it and there
is a whole issue really goes and takes
some artifact to Auntie's Roadshow then
gets told it's worth a few grand and
goes immediately oh yeah let's give it
away but nobody does that it's because
if you go to art galleries and museums
there's all sorts of stuff that's
donated to be seen by wider people it
could be the case here it would be if
there was a white widespread outcry
amongst the Ethiopians
the chances are they're giving this this
something that was given as a gift back
to the Ethiopians and they probably
don't have any value for it has anybody
asked Ethiopia if they even want the
damn thing well right now
hey do you want this road back that's
something
asking whether or not they should be
repatriated
questions because look look if you go to
the British museum it's full of looted
treasure in London the Greeks would
legitimately want back the
parthenonsense
stuff in Greece which belongs to us well
I want it all back well there we are
let's try and do a deal why not you can
see the importance of this
artifacts lines
because I think this is really important
Ethiopia is currently in the middle of a
devastating humanitarian crisis that's
linked to an ethnic conflict
um in the country that has been raging
for a very long time it's nowhere in the
headlines nobody knows anything about
the Tea gray conflict no one's talking
about it at the same time as the
country's been ravaged by climate
breakdown an issue that Ethiopia has
done almost nothing to create which is
largely caused by country in the global
North and this issue of reparations is
all very well and good but let's
actually start thinking about how we can
undo the injustices that are causing the
suffering of those people today and we
don't but I would rather we focus all
our attention on how to improve a lot of
people right now than worrying about
what was going on 300 years ago when
laws morals and ethics were all
completely different now let's try and
end on something a that's hilarious I'm
told because I haven't actually seen
this yet I'm told when it's played to me
I'm going to react in utter horror so
we'll see this is a tick tock video from
Sam Smith
Teletubbies
[Music]
yeah just I don't even know where to
start to see it tomorrow
I don't think there's ever been and I'll
speak of something of an expert in the
genre an attention seeker quite like Sam
Smith and it works
I don't even know how we debate what
I've just watched well he's got a career
as a children's entertainer
it's kind of it's creepy yeah it's kind
of creepy totally agree he's creepy
sounds man no I don't know I mean he's
doing like I would say probably like 60
of the stuff on Tick Tock is creepy
that's like what gets people to watch
you've got the wrong algorithms
really minor golf shots and Ronald
Reagan speeches
and I used to love the Teletubbies now
he's ruined it forever uh anyway great
to see you Pat thank you very much
indeed whatever you're up to uh keep it
a bit like Sam Smith and
good night
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]